so das waren die ersten 15 Minuten der Anstalt
und ich muss gestehen ich bin noch nicht so ganz
überzeugt und damit herzlich willkommen liebe
gebühren-community auf meinem Twitch Kanal ich
bin Samira und diese Livestream ist tätig hier
ist auf keinen Fall der peinliche Versuch der
öffentlich-rechtlichen sich an die Jugend dran
zu Wanzen dafür haben sie auch schon Funk sie
ist für mich nur die perfekte Möglichkeit auf die
gerade laufende Sendung zu reagieren und sorry ich
muss hier aber kurz inhaltspolitesse spielen und
Strafzettel in punkto Polizei Kritik verteilen
die Community sagt nämlich auch good bad cop
Medium Kopf schreibt boring dieses Bashing ja
mir geht es genauso denn in der Sendung ist
mir bisher eindeutig zu wenig Theorie und zu
wenig politische Verantwortung vorgekommen
sagt euch die Brocken Windows theory etwas
also die Theorie der zerbrochenen fansa in dieser
kriminologischen Theorie gegen man davon aus dass
wenn in einem Stadtviertel eine Fensterscheibe
zu Bruch geht und diese nicht sofort repariert
wird nach und nach weitere Scheiben kaputt
gehen wo die schließlich kriminelle Vandalen
herumlungernd angelockt werden bis die
Menschen aufgrund des zunehmenden Verfalls
und der steigenden Zahl der Verbrechen
das Weite suchen also im Grunde wie Berlin
und diese Logik ist oft noch gerne geistige
Grundlage für den Ruf nach mehr Polizei allerdings
wurde diese Theorie sozialwissenschaftlich schon
längst widerlegt das heißt auch wenn die Polizei
ohne Toleranz gegen Obdachlose oder einfach
im öffentlichen Raum vor sich hin existierende
Jugendliche oder drogenabhängige Menschen
durchgreift und vorgeht wird davon Spoiler
Alert keine Fensterscheibe Heil man bekommt
mit mehr Härte und noch schärferen Maßnahmen
erwiesenermaßen die sozialen Bruchstellen
nicht besser in den Griff Blaulicht am Ende
des Tunnels 99 sagt Gefängnisse sind sozialer
Wohnungsbau nirgendwo sind die Mieten günstiger
okay das wird natürlich erklären warum so viele
Münchner so schlecht versuchen die Steuern zu
hinterziehen wenn man sich heutzutage die Aussagen
und Handlungen einiger politiker:innen anschaut
kann man den Eindruck gewinnen dass immer noch
die Vorstellung vorherrscht Polizeikräfte werden
so etwas wie besser ausgerüstete Hausmeister mit
schöneren Uniformen und kleinem Schlüsselbund und
Schlagstöcken verfassbaren Wasserwerfern die
sich um die Instandhaltung des öffentlichen
Raums kümmern müssen wobei die Sicherheit dann auf
gerade zu magische Art und Weise durch allgemeine
Aufgeräumtheit entstehen soll Polizisten
sind in dieser falschen Logik also so was wie
Tatortreiniger bevor die Verbrechen begangen
werden und weil in Deutschland Hausmeister
mindestens genauso beliebt sind wie Ordnungskräfte
glaubt man offenbar weiterhin dass man nur
regelmäßig etwas kräftiger durchwischen muss
damit die Kriminalität aus Angst vor der Ordnung
die Flucht ergreift wann immer also irgendwo
soziale Reibungen auftreten ist es einfacher
nach der polizeilichen Putzkolonne zu rufen als
keine Ahnung ich weiß auch nicht super abwegig die
Politik zu ändern und wie sollte die Polizei auch
mit ihren Mitteln beispielsweise Wohnungsnot oder
Armut bekämpfen eben sie kann ja nicht auf der
Suche nach Wohnraum für obdachlose Menschen mit
richterlichen Beschluss in Deutschland Willen
einbrechen und dort die Menschen unterbringen
nein eine autoritäre Polizei ist für viele
regierende leider immer noch attraktiver als
eine souveräne Sozialpolitik denn autoritäres
durchgreifen simuliert Handlungsfähigkeit meine
Empfehlung als meinungspolizei also an dieser
Stelle dass man die verbalen Wasserwerfer nicht
allein auf die Polizei richtet sondern auch
auf die politische Bequemlichkeit und den
Opportunismus dahinter denn schließlich
muss auch die Polizei mit uns zusammen
diese schlechte Politik ausbaden was meint ihr
schreibt mir eure Kommentare und Meinungen direkt
in den Chat sollte die Polizei vielleicht ihre
Wasserwerfer viel häufiger auf regierende richten
ja meint rosa Polizei fährt aber sie
sollte auch Taser bereithalten denn die
FDP kann man nur technologieoffen bekämpfen
schöne Idee und damit zurück zu Sendung
was vergessen
wo sie abonnieren können
das jetzt noch zwei weitere Videos gucken
können unsere Zuschauer sind ja sehr klug